o pessoal subindo mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer o machado doer
mesmo fazer exatamente pelo personagem
de seus anéis que usa o machado duplo e
pois tem este mês já adquiridos para
mostrar contra os inimigos estavam foi
tanto papel papelão colection e cola piv
a e acho que é só isso mesmo
agora vamos começar o tutorial posso
passar então bora lá
para começar você não precisa imprimir
esse tempo lei
o link está na descrição deste vídeo
hoje eu tenho a parte branca da primeira
e da última folha afirma a folha penso
que template ea última época e assim só
um que no triângulo no canto
a folha de maio vai estar como ela saiu
o que vai ajudar nos a conectar umas
folhas as outras usar agora cola bastão
se vocês não tiverem podem sacola pva ou
então aquela escola escolares que deixa
é muito importante que haja uma
continuação do design de uma folha para
outra hidrovias parte do modo e qual é
um pedaço de cartolina
caso vocês não queiram comprar uma podem
sempre usar uma caixa de cereais de
pequeno-almoço muito importante que
vocês deixem escapar banha cola antes de
começar a cortar porque começaram a
cortar logo folha vai começar a deslizar
em relação a cartolina
recortar e usa um x-ato e tesoura às
vezes o caso vocês sejam crianças peçam
ajuda é um nódulo e claro que não vão
fazer isso em cima da nossa mesa era uma
tábua que vocês possam estrear muito
importante que vocês tirem esses
pequenos triângulos porque eles vão ser
muito importantes mais para frente eles
não há falta de outro eu vou dobrar
agora as linhas usando uma régua
mas se você não tiver é não podem fazer
isso na borda da mesma hora em que a
parte branca fica para dentro de portas
ou para fora e fazer isso nos moldes da
mesma maneira
por outro lado os maus josé cola quente
porque sei que é mais rápido e mais
barato
se vocês não tiverem o conselho que você
compra uma pistola 10 porque vocês
usarem como ipva vai demorar muito tempo
ficaram então uma cola escolar e isso
vai ficar muito chato pra vocês então é
recomendável que vocês comprei uma
pistolinha destas
procurar uma partida lá em cima da outra
e confessou amputado cola por causa da
seca rápido eu vou ganhar no estado
segurei na posição certa e depois conca
cobra desta maneira
esse foi muito bom porque fortaleceu
bastante a parte afiada da família e sim
é conseguir bater algumas coisas com
alguma força não muita muita é mas se eu
bater um pouco e tal não só vai estrear
estou a acabar de fazer a conexão entre
a lâmina e o carro carro vai passar pelo
mais daqui é o cilindro e computar deste
lado pois falta um próximo do outro
agora não está muito bonito mas mais
para frente eu vou cobrir com papel e
vocês vão ver que não se vai notar nada
disso
porque fazer o cabo usar três folhas com
o tamanho a3
agora se vocês não tiverem das folhas
grandes podem usar suas folhas com o
tamanho a4 semana quatro são aquelas
folhas normais de impressora para coar
umas às outras usei que cola pva mas
podem usar cola bastão também fazer
agora uma rifa que é bastante simples e
já ensinei no canal como fazer ela mais
jogar e agora vou enrolar em que o
pedaço grande papel a volta da rifa no
final eu vou ter um tubo que vai ser
mesmo muito resistente porque uma linha
de colas tva para fechar o turno podem
ver tudo ainda é muito pequenino então
vamos fazer algumas coisas para aumentar
o volume é muito importante quando vocês
lembrarem foi uma ipo no colo assim
desta maneira também quando forem
enrolar a volta as folhas vão utilizar
uma em relação à outra e vai ficar assim
foi o cai então é importante você põe um
pouco de cola pva ou então aquela cola
bastão que também serve para fazer duas
faixas
esta é com 4,5 e depois vou fazer outra
com quatro centímetros que da mesma
maneira mas um pouco mais quem for lá a
faixa de 4 a 5 na extremidade oposta
onde o cuca ea outra parte grande e vou
colocar agora uma faixa de 4 centímetros
como podem ver agora está em caixa e não
porque um espacinho mas não tenho
problema nenhum com agora vou colocar
bastante cola quente para esta partida
um pouco crítica você tem que colocar
cola e ficará assegurado na posição
certa técnica e eu fico e sólida para
enfeitar o carro lá e sim um patrocínio
uma fita
desta forma é com vocês como vocês
acharem que vai ficar melhor e podem
acumular fitas para o mesmo lado ou para
o lado oposto e fazer um efeito cruzado
e fazer o efeito cruzado desta vez
porque não última arma
eu fiz as fitas sempre para o mesmo lado
podem ver as partidas acabam começam as
fitas fica fácil então eu coloquei mais
uma faixa com dois jogos em tempo
razoável e depois daqui um pouco outra
faixa do outro lado com 2,5 centímetros
também
a finalizar isto eu fiz aqui uns traços
de cola vai dar assim uns detalhes e vai
ficar mais bonito e hoje
agora vou misturar a água com cola tv há
mais ou menos um para 11 d'água um
decola pv
cortei os pedaços de jornal e vou colar
à volta da arma é bastante simples e é
uma coisa que é bastante engraçado fazer
é pode morar aí mais ou menos nesta
noite talvez 20 minutos
não se podem pôr um fim ao mal à frente
enquanto fazem isso vamos ver depois
desse cara e comecei por pintar usando
uma tinta preta
se vocês tiverem praia é conciliável
fica melhor até para cima também
mas aqui já é um pouco ao vosso gosto
com vocês acharem que vai ficar melhor
que são 38
vou usar castanho e uma tinta que assim
mais pro gol paul era sim uma mistura de
esgoto com castanha parte de cima e que
naquela parte do carro
andrés por ser curto
para pintar estas linhas de cola que eu
coloquei antes usando só a tinta gol
usando uma esponja ems alstom já fiz
assim os detalhes
agora se vocês não tiverem o pincel
podem fazer o vosso próprio cortando uma
esponja daquelas de levar a lusa
vou curtir a parte que eu não quero
pintar usando aquela fica para o pintor
e também pelo sindjornal para não gastar
muita fita
agora eu vou usar máscara e também uns
play no total e com muito funk ou seja
votado e não pinta e se muito perto só
nesta parte lâmina
os cupins ela ainda fiz assim umas
coisas para dar a idéia de desgaste ea
ficou muito bem e chegamos ao fim mas
não só agora vou tirar a proteção e
ficou muito bonito eu acho que vocês
puderem deixar o vosso leque e geografia
e isso motiva bastante
veja aqui o primeiro que eu fiz que a
venda a um custo de diminuir um pouco a
minha espera de um estado em que estava
estudando fazer essa arma e para
finalizar ele estava desafiar um kaká do
canal a cabo é fazer um machado lâmina
dupla
eu sou grande fã do trabalho dela
acompanhe todos os vídeos por pra mim
ela é uma inspiração e mostrou bastante
para fazer coisas mais elaboradas mais
bonitinhas e eu agradeço por isso e hoje
seria do fiel a fazer um machado lâmina
dupla e mesmo se ele vai aceitar o vai
fazer isso não vai ser ver o que vai
sair
o livro era leão está na edição deste
livro que prossigamos enfim muito
obrigado pelo pai só até à próxima
champions